all right gamers welcome to the ultimate
running away from storm map I'm here at
my friend I'm not in hey which one do I
do it
come here my best gamer Lindsay PI might
have heard of him he's an up-and-coming
fortnight's dreamer smash like if you're
excited for the next event I will
support him in his fortnight in Denver's
[Music]
gaming week they gave me day three baby
grab you grab your gaming partner
jacksepticeye woods dude what's up
gamers my it's summer my hats on
backwards and I'm ready to party may
make sure it's subscribe and like let's
just have fun guys let's do have fun it
literally says that oh yeah we're
debating what the best title for this
would be yeah for the world title
the hidden black mirror episode mom
hacked my basement no way this is pop
hot baby regime odd now gaming week baby
anything can happen
don't forget to support the Creator I
don't know what my Creator code is in
fortnight pewdiepie if you want more
fortnight content be sure to leave a
comment down below this is Julie's Ash a
like button also the top 5,000 hundred
comments for the first 30 minutes of
this video so I hope to see you there
epic gamers can't wait to see what your
egg gamers are gonna say if you guys are
hyped about for tonight let me know down
in the comments below
hey what do you guys think of the new
for that update I'd have no weed input
whatsoever but do tell me update night
update night okay I don't know how this
works
yeah we're playing a game the worst
gamers okay so you're hiding and I have
to find you oh this is how it works okay
alright jackaboy we're okay prop ping
Ping's me right now and then I think I
heard something over here does that mean
I have to keep constantly switching
position nearly see you moving no wait
that's a balloon shut up Felix alright
give me a hint what do you smell like
I'm whistling at you I don't know what
the pings are doing by the way I don't
know what the coins are anything works
ok it's definitely coming from here
right is it no it's coming from here are
you next to me you up there
oh wait a soirée enter code
jacksepticeye guys where are you are you
two buds are not the bus well hey are
you the soda props won that round you
killed yourself gamer week that was a
big boys locker room
look me and the boys just playing prop
hunt in fortnight this is 2019 gaming
were you the soda though no I would say
little like cooler next to it oh my god
you shot the soda and killed yourself oh
not a gamer way bro that's the gamer way
ok so guys Oh the way this works is that
now is my turn to be the prop and jack
has to find me if you want to join it to
win an Xbox call me your favorite
jacksepticeye video wait do I have to
damage myself to get out of here uh I
don't know how I just hit the barn doors
yes but prop won't you damage yourself
by ok yes hi oh there we go
about baby okay that's the Train all
right Oh God guys we have to be careful
because now jacksepticeye is looking for
except the guys on the hunt baby
jacksepticeye okay found the until me
challenge impossible question mark
jacksepticeye is a fortnight hacker
okay let's keep an ear out for this ping
I didn't hear it
I didn't hear Dukie the first time see
I'd never hear the ping what crazy this
is so weird
okay what's the coin just I don't know
you collect the coins apparently I don't
Oh guys oh well I heard it what did you
hear I heard the ping you didn't hear
anything I'm so far away guys are you
PewDiePie I don't know guys this is epic
[Music]
it's new master 69 here
telling you to subscribe to all your
favorite gaming channels doesn't even
have to be me should be me though
subscribe
use your fortnight creator codes like
use any of your favorite creators but
I'm really saying it's an use of you
guys it's all about giving you have to
be a giving person Paris this game to me
you make fun of my accent I'm a prop II
boy right now what am I gonna what am I
gonna be gamers quick guys down in the
comments let me know what I should be
[Laughter]
good guys he's coming so annoying oh
okay guys I think I heard a whistle over
here here he comes
did you just throw a boogie bomb at me
you threw a bogey bar back at your
favorite gamer that's what it's gaming
week everybody
smash like if you're excited for gaming
the title of this video should be how
can we make the most generic obnoxious
let's play another wish I think I would
make it what it actually is it's their
boobs it fortnight verbs in finite does
boobs okay but don't trick me alright
you can't trick on gamer week where
you're dancin buddy
wait are you dancing too okay guys now
ah oh my god oh my god worried see bite
me
alright guys helped me to find
jacksepticeye right no no that breath
sorry about that brides gaming week I'm
sure you understand did you just did you
just have a gamer moment
watch out PewDiePie this gamers coming
for your number one spot oh I see you
time for the jacksepticeye shout out
number three you gotta earn it bruh oh I
heard ping ping comes from this
direction
Oh amateur didn't even close the door
after him he did a swore he did a swore
oh please
I peed he'll never find me are you here
PewDiePie oh ah wait wait wait wait what
will we wait I'm not waiting for nothing
okay oh god I'm scared Bros Bros what do
i do what do i do bro okay go hide again
it's because I can hear footsteps
alright you'll never find gamer I'll
never dance for you Jack you here
somewhere
uh yeah you heard me
oh crap no I'm less do fortnight portal
crossover okay okay that sounds epic
alright gamers let us know in the
comments if that sounds that big alright
guys if you have not subscribed yet
we're doing a subscriber challenge so
join the broski's can you subscribe for
24 hours challenge whoever subscribes
for the most times gets $10,000 oh man
I'm not allowed to play with you Jack
that sucks bro Pro this is not game
where I'm going back to the hub okay do
you wanna do you wanna just do this oh
heck yeah bro let's let's freakin do it
oh yeah oh let's just jump in okay I'll
get it so you glide into this hole bro I
have no idea where you are tonight over
here I'm here oh you're all the way over
there I'm the complete opposite side
come here brat come on gamer okay I'm
coming in dropping hot is this tilted
mid rolls every one minute oh yeah
that's my gamer boy yeah press B no no
freakin way
that's not the right song though you got
to do it again that is the right one if
this video gets a hundred thousand
million likes oh no wait that's too much
if this video gets a million likes me
and Jack will do a four-night IRL
challenge all right jack oh god
all right you really good at this deck
you're not big dude I thought no else
who's your favorite custom map creator
in favorite every creator you know what
this these custom apps are really good
real estate in Fortnight custom maps I'm
thinking about buying a housing for
tonight smash like to take out a
mortgage to buy B bucks
enter code beautiful free ebooks for
anyone who has a fortnight real estate I
think oh I'm willing to take give out a
loan of 500 beat books 500 Amazon gift
codes all right I have not seen you do
we both just die instantly yeah I think
yes jumping I think the momentum has to
keep going or something well you have to
wait for a game are you letting let me
know let me know if you wanna see also
that adds wait I get it this is just
trying over and over and over head yeah
I'm already bored you gotta jump at the
very last second oh man
I'm just gonna be over here eating epic
popcorn dude you took an L how does that
feel
I take Noelle's you said jump in the
last second bruh bruh no I want to do it
because it's gaming week and gaming oh
my god I'm just I'm just gonna leave you
have to support a fellow gamer is this
what gamers actually want to do in
fortnight right now yes Ohio Brook Brook
I did it did you I don't believe you
okay have you waited for your fellow
gamer you wouldn't know dude I'm too
busy taking elves over here I don't have
time to oh yeah
[Laughter]
the secret is to glide to the second one
no bro that's I dunno fuli's know fully
there's something beautiful about
watching you just for wait are you still
down there oh no right come on please
make it out make it out you can bait the
traps oh really
yeah alright watch I got to do this one
for my bros
oh yeah oh I made it I'm up here did you
die yeah I left oh alright gamers let's
finish this off with style let's let's
play the wall all right guys we're
playing the wall it's a new challenge in
fortnight it's pretty yes video gets a
million likes ninja will join us why are
we shooting that you see the orange ones
oh oh guys is a new challenge in
fortnight oh wow this is so cool
so we're like shooting the machines and
stuff that's really awesome no no this
is so cool
oh shoot dude I got a mini alright guys
this has been epic for night time with
my friend jacksepticeye what it's not
over yet okay well keep all right guys
let's remain positive here it's gaming
weak support you enter I don't know I
don't even know where you went
now you tell you who tell me I didn't I
didn't change anyway right guys here we
are in the new fortnight portal oh yeah
whoa okay so this is cool
so like I'm in the four nine portal okay
Oh have you guys played before - that's
one of my favourite game the cake is a
lie Aperture Science I have all their
merch oh I hate you we're not leaving
the game
we're just even creative for like two
seconds and then we're gonna drop drop
Jaime Hilton its gaming week it's game
take you out of my life
all right Jack look at me once again all
right this is me every day of the year
Wow during gaming week is that is that
your face wait the joke my face where my
friend is dancing in fortnight this is
me when my I inherited money this is me
when I'm at my granddad's funeral and I
don't want to just dab I want to do a
gentleman's dab see that's respect gamer
is face my granddad's for all okay do
for a cop adventure
oh yeah
so I was shooting me that's not ps-aguié
desu oh I think you have to shoot him
for me we have to work together you're
naming me be higher gamer oh wait wait
wait I got I need to help you okay go
over to the wall and it's gaming way to
the very edge this is good no this is
gonna be epic
alright what what okay okay okay when
the bomb lands okay three do what gaming
we're all about teamwork with your
friends I'm gonna get into this
super-sick go-kart that my mom bought me
oh you can get in as well
oh we're together now this is gaming
week Wow how do I do I actually have to
wait what okay alright so this is how
you do the driving week style gaming wig
oh you want to get that porta fortress
dude oh heck yeah but always a gamer bro
first there's so many doors this is so
cool like which door is it gonna be and
then next time what doors are gonna be
after that one like what I gotta use the
main menu and select back to hub to
return there I don't want to return
there so it's the middle right here oh
wait is this expose it on it shows it on
the map oh the map of the top right this
is me when the chat is gonna be not stop
harassing alright guys looks like we
didn't through the challenge but gate
smash likes he wants part to invest
no we should continue this is me when
all my when I get a million likes on the
video what you never played tuber
simulator you know it's fun right I'm
not supposed to give my opinion but give
it a try and then you can tell me if
it's good or not not convinced yet okay
I'll cut you a deal
the game is available for free and
that's a great price
[Music]